former British Army intelligence and
security officer Philip Ingram and
Philip good to see you what do we know
about the attacks that happened
overnight yeah the Russians have gone
back to attacking centers population and
critical National infrastructure so they
attacked three cities
um uh leviv right in the very West
um which is they haven't attacked much
in the past Kiev the capital and
zaparisia and we can see some of the
damage and this this is this is in the
Kiev
um 35
um Kamikaze drones
um 32 were shot down or 35 missiles
altogether some of them were the caliber
cruise missiles which have got that
longer range but the ukrainians are
having great success in shooting them
down however a few got through big
amounts of explosives on them and they
caused a lot of damage on the ground and
a lot of reports about what's happening
in a counter-offensive and the deputy
defense minister for Ukraine has said
today that the biggest blow in kiev's
counter-offensive is yet to come you
haven't seen anything yet as it were
yeah the the ukrainians set the
conditions for people not to quite
understand the complexity of what's
going on at the moment last year
whenever they took a big chunk of land
and heart cave in the Northeast back
very quickly indeed and they took a big
chunk on Harrison in the South back as
well this is very different this
counter-offensive they're still in a
probing phase they're attacking in sort
of three real areas bakmut which
um the Russians had spent a year trying
to capture
um they're they're moving in there just
south of Donetsk and then from um Don
zaparesia down towards the coast down
towards meliopol and trying to cut that
land bridge and they're looking for gaps
in the Russian defenses they're probing
the Russian defenses to see if they can
get weaknesses to then get the real
armored punch and push it through they
haven't made the decision to do that yet
but this is the Russians have had an
awful lot of time to prepare the ground
the really deliberate defenses in there
they will slow the ukrainians down but
the ukrainians have to be slow and
deliberate in what they're doing
otherwise a danger when they move
they're larger armored permissions that
that they will get hit quite hard so
this is very very different they're
having some successes at the moment the
ukrainians have taken you've certainly
done in this upper Asia area up to seven
kilometers of penetrated Russian
defensive lines in only a couple of
weeks the Russians that took them
um over a year to get five kilometers so
that's putting it into perspective okay
Philip Thank You Phillip Ingram there